my story begins with a phone call in
screenwriting terms we might think of it
as the disturbance and it certainly
disturbed me it's 6:30 a.m. I know
immediately that it's my u.s. agent
Jerry collation a six foot six a minion
American attack dog with a heart of gold
who would walk over glass for his
clients but no matter how many times I
explained that Australia is not on la
time he doesn't get it for Jerry there
is only la time and he always calls at
6:30 a.m. I answer my phone and reach
for a cigarette I can't do one without
the other but I'm giving up smoking and
they're not there where they should be
and as Jerry speaks in a faltering voice
and tries to sound calm which is not
easy for an LA agent they don't do calm
but as Jerry is speaking I keep reaching
for my cigarettes even though I know
that I'm not there I even start to lift
up scattered pieces of paper on my desk
the fragments of screenplays the unread
articles the unpaid bills looking for
cigarettes that I know aren't there
because Jerry is telling me that the
producers of the film Edge of Darkness
which I've been working on for five
years which is dominated my life and the
life of my family which has caused my
gray hair to turn white and driven me to
the edge of sanity and I'm not kidding
sanity was a casualty
it is regained now but I have stared
into the abyss of breakdown because of
this project and Jerry is now telling me
that the producers have decided to bring
on another writer and I'm silent until
Jerry says for Christ's sake you're
killing me say something and so I say
why two weeks ago we were going to make
it well two weeks is a long time in
Hollywood and things seem to have
changed
Jerry is talking again he is saying
they're bringing this guy on just to do
a dialogue polish just to Americanize it
to locate it more strongly in Boston
where the film is set and this guy's
from Boston he knows it really well
he'll he probably won't even take a
credit I'm mildly reassured who is this
say oh he's name is bill Monahan what's
he done oh he wrote The Departed and I
mean you mean the departed that one the
best screenplay Oscar yeah that's the
one and I'm reaching for my cigarettes
that aren't there again because I don't
know much but I know that you don't hire
an oscar-winning writer to do a dialogue
polish and an oscar-winning writer does
not pick up someone else's work without
taking credit I mean the guy does not
need to ghostwrite
right or anybody and then I hear Jerry
say something I'll never forget
there's no shame in this this happens to
every writer in Hollywood from the
lowest to the best this happens to
everyone and I say yes but it doesn't
make it right
and when I get off the phone my hand
reaches for the cigarettes that aren't
there and I call Martin Campbell the
director of the film and I say Martin
what's going on is absolutely nothing to
worry about he says but I say Martin if
you need to do this if we have come to
the end of some kind of Road then I
understand it's been great but he'll I
understand and I'm lying of course I
don't want him to do this I don't want
to be replaced the film means too much
to me
and has cost me too much the best part
of five years and as I said before my
sanity and Martin says emphatically
Monahan is coming on to just to do a
Polish to Americanize the dialogue and
to locate it more strongly in Boston
nothing will change it will remain all
your work you were the screenwriter of
Edge of Darkness there is no shame in
this this happens to every writer in
Hollywood I think to myself and so I get
off the phone and I email one of the
film's producers and I say I understand
that you're bringing on Bill Monahan
I've been told by Martin that it's just
a dialogue polish can you clarify the
situation for me and the producer emails
back and says absolutely bill is just
doing a Polish to Americanize the
dialogue it is business as usual there's
nothing to worry about and I reached for
the cigarettes that aren't there and I
think to myself maybe this isn't so bad
maybe this hotshot oscar-winning writer
will come on and iron out the rough
patches and give it a Hollywood shine at
the same time I'm thinking it's the
rough patches that make this screenplay
what it is and Hollywood shine is
of everything I've fought against
through the last seven drafts my story
doesn't really begin with Jerry's phone
call at all that that was more like the
second act plot point the turn in the
script that moves us rently relentlessly
towards the crisis the story began much
earlier so whilst Bill Monahan gets on
with polishing muck the dialogue on my
script I'll take you back to the
all-important set up in 2002 or maybe
2003 and I'm a happy playwright bringing
up three kids with eugenia on a farm
south of Adelaide and I've recently
written a film called Lantana and it is
done that thing that we all hope our
work will do it is connected with an
audience and broken out and after doing
very good business in at the Australian
box office it has played at several
festivals and been sold into the
European and the all-important American
market and I'm sitting back enjoying it
all from a distance thinking what would
be next when the phone starts to ring
somebody wants me to write a film for
DeNiro my head was spinning and it was
that easy one day a playwright with
roots in left-wing political theatre in
Melbourne the next and in-demand
Hollywood writer but the phone call that
really made me stop was the one from
Martin Campbell asking me to adapt
Troy Kennedy Martin's 1980s BBC
television series Edge of Darkness into
a feature film but why me I asked I have
just watched your film Lantana and
you're exactly the writer we're looking
for someone outside of the Hollywood
system who won't be a slave to plot plot
and genre and who can write [ __ ] good
dialogue Martin said and within a couple
of weeks I was on a plane to Los Angeles
flying first-class hell I hadn't even
fly business class before and after the
first glass of champagne and the tasty
little treats I knew I was ruined how
would I ever fly economy class again
maybe I wouldn't have to maybe this is
my life now and so I made out that I
belong to that rarefied world at the
front end of the plane along with rich
American retirees and CEOs of major
international corporations and the odd
famous person but I was in LA of course
to meet Martin and the film's producers
and Martin had a suite of offices at the
old MGM Studios which were now owned by
Sony and even though it has become a
Disney version of a Hollywood studio you
could still feel the history of the
place and I had to admit it was a buzz
to be a part of it
the first meeting was with Martin and
Michael wearing the producer of the
original TV series who like Martin would
become a good friend overcoming years
David Thompson head of beast at BBC
Films who were partners in the project
was always there was also there or at
least he was on the loudspeaker and
finally there was Dan risen er an
old-school Hollywood producer who had
been around for a long time and who had
seen it all before and I liked Dan a lot
after the first draft he said love it
now let's make the [ __ ] thing after
the fourth draft he found me an
Australian gave me some good advice
which I fully understand then but which
makes a lot of sense to me now
he said you know this film is ready to
be made this script won't get any better
and if you keep working on it you're
just going to go backwards his theory is
that too many drafts kill a film and you
just go around in circles changing
things just because you can and you end
up close to where you started and I
didn't believe him at the time I'm an
obsessive perfectionist it's very easy
for me to unravel my own work which is
what I did over and over on edgy
darkness but I'm jumping ahead of myself
essentially I was meant to go into that
meeting and pitch for the film but I
don't pitch well and I had no idea if
they were talking to other writers or
not I found out later they were but then
I didn't know that so I didn't realize
it was a competitive situation and I'm
glad I didn't because the pressure would
have been too much I just would have
said give it to the other guy I'm going
back to the farm so I didn't pitch I and
I think there are a little surprise but
what I did instead was to talk as
thoughtfully as I could about the story
and the people in it and I think they
were a relief to hear this Australian
guy talking about this imagined film
without the usual
packaging of the Hollywood pitch because
what a pitch does is reduce something
down to its simplest digestible form
where for me it's about opening up to
its widest possibilities but after we
had talked for a good hour or so about
the politics of the film and its genre
and what it meant to relocate a work
conceived and made in Thatcher's England
to bushes America I talked about what
really mattered to me I said this is a
film about grief this is about a father
who loses his daughter in violent
circumstances and doesn't understand why
and he feels guilty because every bone
in his body
tells him that he should have been able
to protect her and he couldn't he
couldn't save her and that's his
emotional dilemma
and I have a daughter and I just
couldn't bear it if I lost her I think I
would go crazy and I could see it in
their faces I fake faces I had clinched
the job not because I impressed them
with her with my understanding of
structure or genre or politics or the
politics of the piece but because I
understood the emotional terrain of the
film
I understood the emotional experience
that would be given to the audience and
that's what they wanted that emotional
understanding once I got home from Los
Angeles the challenges of the adaptation
quickly became apparent how'd it take
six hours of story and make it work in
two not only was it was a shift in time
required from Thatcher's England to
Bush's America but a radical shifting
culture was required
the British tongue-in-cheek irony of
Troyes work was not going to play well
in America being an ex-spy Troy had
knowledge about how clandestine
government operations worked I had no
idea and I had to find out quickly
suffice to say that the research on this
was fascinating and the plot as it
developed revolved around the collusion
between private industry and hawkish
sectors of the bush regime to develop a
new and secret nuclear weapon and to
create the political circumstances in
which they would be justified to use it
the first draft took me about six months
to research and write and finally it was
delivered and I was on my way to London
to discuss it with Martin Michael David
Thompson Jamie Lawrence and from the
babys BBC the strength of the first
draft was that I had wrestled the
material into a into the shape of a
feature film it now looked like a film
and not a television series it had a
taut and gripping first act that would
hardly change over the subsequent draft
it had a cumbersome second act with some
good scenes and a third act that
required Craven and the infamous
Jedburgh
to break into a nuclear facility in
order to find the proof that this weapon
existed it didn't work and it would
continue to trouble me right through the
writing process just as the last act of
the TV series of troubled Troy but I
learned something important in London
after delivering the draft I wrote a
comprehensive set of notes
deconstructing my own my own work and
laying out what needed to happen in the
second draft perhaps they did this to
preempt criticism but it worked
there were 12 people in the script
meeting our edge team had grown and all
the money people now had several people
on board I had flown in from Australia
for the meeting and several people had
flown in from LA and Martin began it by
saying well I think under has done a
terrific job with the first draft and
you've all read his comprehensive notes
so we should just let him get on with it
don't you think and there was general
agreement around the table and that was
it the meeting was over of course all
Martin had done was to clear some space
so that he and I and Michael and Jamie
could get on with the more concentrated
and detailed work that was required I
went mad right in the second and third
drafts I don't know what happened but I
reached my own Edge of Darkness you
might think that would experience the
art of writing a good spricht screenplay
will get easier but strangely at least
for me the opposite is true the more I
know about it the more difficult it has
become it is almost as if I know too
much and knowing too much compared Eliza
with self-doubt because you know when
you're getting it wrong
you know when it's not good enough and
that's deadly that voice in your head
that is telling you it's not good enough
I guess I had writer's block
and for those of you who have
experienced that you know how
debilitating that can be Martin was in
Prague making Casino Royale
so Michael Waring came out to Australia
to talk me through it and we drank a lot
of red wine and I made him help me pick
out all of it pick our olive crop and
then he went back to England and I
continued writing the first 30 pages
again and again again and then something
shifted or rather lifted
and I think it had something to do with
my children the older ones were becoming
adolescents and they needed a father in
the house not a neurotic writer and my
youngest kid I don't know what it was
but he just loved and loved me like he
could sense I was in danger and so he
just kissed and hugged me out of
depression he used to walk at my side
and he needed to have a part of his body
touching mine all the time I thought it
was because he needed reassuring now I
think it's because he at seven or eight
ensured of Lee understood that I was the
one that needed to be reassured and he
made me laugh he cracked me I have time
and time again with the laugh and with
the laughter the depression and the
writer's block started to lift it was
also about money things were lean on the
home front and the only way I knew how
to earn a buck was to write and so I
pulled my finger out and I wrote and
suddenly the fourth draft was done and
delivered and then Martin was on the
phone about [ __ ] time darling he
occasionally called me darling and it's
brilliant he said suddenly a new
producer was on the scene none other
than the oscar-winning producer Graham
King and I'm back in first-class flying
to LA now grand King is a little scary
he's a great big guy from east from the
East End of London with big hands that
could crush you maybe if he wanted to
but he loves the scripting he knows how
to make a movie in Hollywood and the
word is that Mel Gibson has read it and
he's interested in playing Kraven and so
Graham puts the hard word on me you've
got milk Mel Gibson wanting to do this
film so how quickly can you do the next
pass and I say how quickly do you want
it and he says yesterday and it's back
on the plane when I do the Mel pass and
I wait and I wait and I wait and then a
call comes from Martin get on the next
plane no wants to meet so I'm back on
the plane to LA but I'm in business
class and oh god it's the beginning of
the end they've downgraded me but the
next day I'm in a meeting with Mel
Gibson and mark good a--from icon with
Martin and Graham and lot other people
and they're keen but Mel thinks the
stakes need to be raised and my heart
cracks a little because I know where
this is going and when we workshop that
idea a little more we drop the Iran idea
and we drop the whole nuclear backdrop
and we come up with a plot that has
clandestine elements within the US
government plotting an act of
terrorism on US soil with the intention
of framing terrorist elements abroad and
therefore justifying Bush's absurd war
on terror and subsequent US foreign
policy the only problem is that man and
I don't believe such a thing is credible
or true and Mel does he's convinced of
it and on the surface it seems like a
good Hollywood plot but that's exactly
what it is a Hollywood plot and that was
exactly the kind of thing I'd been
trying to avoid and always fought for
the film to be it's about something that
was happening in order for it to be
politically relevant and seeing that
truth would be the casualty and when
Martin and I had time to reflect on this
to his credit he backed away from this
idea but we had to come up with a
scenario that was true but also
addressed Mills and Graham's concerns of
the stakes needing to be raised in other
words Milo Burns style wasn't going to
cut it and the pressure was now on we
worked for two days and nights and then
presented the new idea to Graham and his
fellow producers they seemed to back it
they seemed to like it and then Graham
reminded me that the u.s. writer's
strike was due to start in three weeks
if the film was going to go then we
would need a script before that I said I
could do it but secretly I shuddered I
didn't tell Graham this though I just
said I could do it and then something
odd happened Martin asked me to leave
the room so that he could have a chat
with Graham and he had never asked me to
leave a meeting before and I knew it was
over I felt it in my bones
somewhere along the line along the way
they had decided that I wasn't up to it
and they were in there discussing
contingency plans and I stood outside
the building and rolled a cigarette and
thought they're not taking this away
from me
I've got three weeks before the strike
starts I couldn't do this and I did I
wrote like a demon I was the full
catastrophe the cliched writer writing
day and night living on cigarettes and
coffee growling at the kids and I could
do that when I was 20 but it was taking
its toll now but I just kept reminding
myself that this was a story about a man
who loses his daughter and it has to
know why and if he doesn't find out he
will lose his mind this was about a man
going mad and I was going mad at the
time so really I knew something about it
and I finished it two days before the
strike and send it silence one day two
days a week then Martin calls and says
he's happy but it's with Mel I hear
nothing from Graham's office so I'm
email and asked what he thinks and his
words are chilling he says it's the best
it's ever been and maybe to some people
that sounds good but I knew exactly what
it meant it wasn't what I wanted to hear
because he was telling me that it's the
best it's ever been but it's still not
good enough
and then it and then there's the strike
and things go quiet for a long time then
one day the phone rings at 6:30 a.m. and
I know it's Jerry because Jerry is on La
time and I'm reaching for my cigarettes
that aren't there and Jerry tells me
that Bill Monahan is doing a Polish but
there's nothing to worry about my agent
the director the producer have all told
me that it's just a dialogue polish Edge
of Darkness
is your screenplay and it always will be
and then there it was splashed across
the pages of variety oscar-winning
writer bill Monahan on board for a page
one rewrite for a Gibbs for the Gibson
vehicle it was a big story and it didn't
include me and I found out because of an
article in variety hell that's Hollywood
Martin eventually sent me bill script
and it was a difficult and strange to
read it because it wasn't my working yet
it was there were traces it was like
looking through the surface of something
and seeing the shadow of yourself beyond
it it was like being painted over I was
angry I was upset I emailed Martin and
said that bill has just pissed over six
years pissed all over six years of work
all those great scenes all those great
moments those shocking reveals and
Cravens terrible pain and grief as he
came to terms with his the loss of his
daughter gone I didn't hear back and
never heard from him again I never heard
from the producers either gone I like to
think that they were too ashamed to face
me but really I think they just moved on
I think they had to they had a film to
make bill script was slick and fast
paced the writing was sharp polished
there was a clear sense of three of
three act structure and he hit all the
right structural moments
and yet it read like many other American
screenplays I had read and it had lost
many of the qualities that distinguished
it from any other Hollywood thriller my
script was dense and tried to convey too
much information bills script was clear
but it conveyed hardly any information
at all my script retained the essence of
Troy's work and even some of his iconic
moments including the infamous kissing
of the dildo moment for those who know
the series nothing of Troy's work is
retained in bill script or the eventual
film not even a central character's name
which had shifted from Ron K Craven to
Thom Craven for some reason my script
was about a post-911 loss of confidence
in what it meant to be American bill
script was a reassertion of confidence
in America my script was about moral
shades of grey' Bill's script was about
moral certainties good and evil black
and white in my script the protagonists
didn't kill anyone he solved his
problems through his intellectual Nelse
in bill script he killed anyone who got
in his way
my script sought to distance trucked the
ideological framework that had defined
America Bill's script embodied and
celebrated that ideology whether
intentionally or not that's just what
those kind of movies do that the rights
of the individual must be asserted of
the rights of the group and that if
someone does you wrong it is your right
as an American to seek redress in any
way you choose this is the very ideology
that America used to explain and justify
their response to 9/11 Edge of Darkness
began as a critique of this ideology and
ended up upholding it that's Hollywood I
don't blame anyone for what happened on
edge of darkness I don't blame gran and
the other producers they had a movie to
make they had a responsibility and I
don't blame Mel he delivered his
customary strong and charismatic
performance and I certainly don't blame
Martin who stood by me for so long
I don't even blame Bill his work may
have begun as a dialogue polish but I
know what happens I've done it you
changed this you changed that and then
you need to change the thing that set it
up and all of a sudden you're doing a
page one
if I blame anyone I blame myself in the
end I could not give them what they
wanted and that was my job but when I
finally read bills script and saw what
it was that they had wanted I knew that
that was not something I could give
I wasn't that writer I tell my kids that
it doesn't matter if you make a mistake
as long as you learn from it it's a
cliche but I believe it probably means I
haven't always followed my own advice
it's the player ID in me I look for the
cause for the thing that must be
revealed the wrong that must be put
right I wonder sometimes whether being a
playwright with those instincts is
compatible with working in the film
industry I think it is if you can
achieve the alchemy between political
context and the demands of good story if
you can set a story about human need and
desire against the politics of the times
if you ask the question what's going on
in the world when this story happens
because every story is shaped by the
times and place in which it is set the
question is do audiences care about this
nuanced balance between politics and the
demands of genre our audience is
interested in a more difficult subject
matter the more complex films does
content matter a quick study of box
office figures would suggest that they
don't most of the audience continues to
look to cinema to escape from the lives
they lead rather to be confronted by
them and I get that but should we then
write to that audience alone the call
from some quarters in the last few years
has been that we should write films that
people actually want to see they say but
what does that mean write films of happy
endings write films about likable people
write films that give people a sense of
hope write films that last 90 minutes
write fast films write genre kill people
because audiences like that
fair enough but those films will always
be written to market demands it and
plenty of films that set out to do
exactly that fail anyway if we heat this
core it is the films that don't set out
to do that which are at risk the tougher
films the darker films the quieter and
slower films the political films I'm not
interested in escaping anything in the
argument around whether the image of the
drowned Syrian child
i Kerdi should be shown on social media
I was firmly of the opinion that it
should it happened it's true images are
powerful that one shocked the West
action followed I love a film that tells
it as it is I love a savage brutal
miserable account of life are quite like
a melancholy mood I'm not afraid of the
dark of human failing I don't always
want to see someone win in the end so
many films scream cry now
cry cry cry most of the time it's too
easy I and I admire a film that amends
my tears and what makes me feel
something more than anything is when a
film reveals just how savage or banal
life can be and that a human being can
actually survive it so I'm a playwright
with a political impulse always looking
for a way to land it in the context of
film I've made mistakes and have pushed
the politics too hard but I'm also
guilty of doing the opposite and letting
the politics slip away from a project
softening it on the assumption that a
more palatable version might prove might
prove to draw a broader audience in my
opinion the more palatable version of
anything never works as a screenwriter I
pride myself on being able to work
collaborative
collaboratively towards realizing the
vision for a film I'm often asked what
is the secret to a successful
collaboration it's really simple there
are two points the first is sake to say
yes to other people's ideas the good
ideas will last and the bad ones will
fall by the wayside naturally but if you
say no at the beginning the idea is
never tested and you will never know if
it would have flown and in the meantime
you have silenced your collaborator the
second secret to a successful
collaboration is not to seek to control
the outcome this one is a little more
complex a little more difficult it
requires trust and confidence in the
people you're working with and above or
the capacity to put your ego aside this
sits at odds with the idea that a film
is the result of the sole vision of a
director is it possible that in cinema
we genuflect to the idea of the director
as soul of turtle
and therefore that the director feeling
that the vision is theirs to carry alone
often fails to deliver it
the alternative to still argue for the
potential of a collective vision a
radical approach perhaps until you
realize that most television drama is
actually the result of a shared vision
arising from a from the collective work
of a creative team and it's worth
pointing out that much of the most
interesting the most compelling the most
groundbreaking storytelling for the past
decade or so has been taking place on a
small screen I wonder if it's time for
cinema to recapture that ground it's
we've all it's always regarded itself as
the sirak superior form but it's time to
take a lesson from the way television
drama is created at the end of the shoot
on Lantana ray lawrence the director
printed up a t-shirt for everyone
involved in the film on the front it
said Lantana and on the back it said a
film by and then it listed the names of
everybody who had anything to do with
the film from the director himself to
the names of the catering crew in
alphabetical order fortunately I was
quite near the top it's a symbolic
gesture but one that reflected the
spirit in which the film was made ray
also chose not to have a possessory
credit such as a Ray Lawrence film at
the front of the picture opting instead
for a simple directed by in the end
credits another indication I think of
the spirit in which the film was made as
the writer of Lanterna ray and Joan
Chapman the film's producer made three
important gestures towards me the first
was to hold a reading of the screenplay
with the cast with the cast for the crew
and for everybody had financed the film
it's not always possible but it served
to share the story with everybody who
was about to make it and therefore to
give them a sense of ownership and
investment in it and it was a mark of
respect to the screenplay
and to its writer it said this document
matters the second was to ask me to be
on a set as much as possible so the
person who knew the mechanics of the
story best its writer could provide the
solutions to new problems as they arose
in the shoot the third was to welcome me
into the Edit room
just welcome me but to recognize that my
insights were a value so so often a
screenwriter is only invited into the
Edit room towards the end of the process
but unless you've seen the steps made to
arrive at the point you're at it's very
difficult to deconstruct what's there in
order to offer meaningful and effective
feedback you're reduced to simply
endorsing what you see encouraging
what's going on you know it's a process
it's just that you're not a part of it I
hold Lantern rap as a model for
accessible collaboration in film and I
believe that the film's success
reflected the way it was made those of
us who write for the screen of familiar
with the argument that the screenplay is
a blueprint the architectural plan for
the film it has no artistic value or
point beyond that some of us might
actually agree with it I think it is
that but it's not only that
architectural plans are more than a set
of instructions they contain a vision so
does a screenplay the screenplay whether
written for the big or small screen must
capture the imagination and inspire the
director and the other artists
particularly the actors it must enable
them to do their best work by engaging
their intellect and their in stick
instincts it must win the confidence of
those who will finance it by being clear
in its intent and sharp in its execution
it must carry the possibility of the
film and evoke the experience that will
be offered for its audience it must
convey pace and rhythm and tone it must
offer the most vivid images and reveal
the complexities of human behavior not
through the interior voice that's
available to the novelist but through
what a character does what a character
says and what a character fails to say
and do a good screenplay is like a fine
poem with a maximum amount of meaning
possible is expressed with as fewer
words as possible we're what sits on the
page is the tip of the iceberg and the
portal to the depth of meaning that is
often left unsaid in order to allow room
for the camera to reveal what's hidden
often the best dialog simply frames the
moment writing a screenplay is about
creating the space for an actor to fill
the camera is at its most revealing in
the spaces between what it said
in the silence and stillness of the
moments in between and of more and more
interest to me as a rider is not what
the character says but their struggle to
say it their search for meaning in the
words and actions they use to describe
their world not so much what they convey
but their failure to convey it that's
art that's literature that's whatever
you want to call it but it's not just a
set of instructions that may or may not
be followed it is an organic document
that continues to change as the film is
shot and edited but I strongly believe
that the vision of the film is to be
found first in the words on a page I
really am against the notion that the
female writers should write the female
characters and the male writers write
the male characters I mean what is
writing if not the attempt to put
yourself in other people's shoes we were
in this production office in in Dublin
and I I went upstairs and I borrowed
somebody's computer and I wrote the
scene in probably 30 minutes
you